okay what if aliens actually embedded
Earth if you've seen pretty much any
Hollywood film you've definitely thought
about it but basically if it happens for
real there's a few things you need to
know first the good news is that long
before you need to worry about an alien
and vision we have to make first contact
with aliens or even just find any
evidence that they're out there at all
we have been looking we've got loads of
observatories searching the stars and
we've been listening to radio waves from
nearby galaxies looking for any signal
so far we find nothing but what if thing
is finding aliens will be one of the
biggest events in human history but
officially there's almost no plan for
what to do in 1989 this very catchy
document was developed on what to do if
you receive a signal from
extraterrestrials their bold
recommendation just tell the UN but what
next the way we've collectively
responded to recent Global threats isn't
exactly reassuring but maybe discovering
aliens could create some unlikely
alliances during the Cold War Gorbachev
agreed that Russia would help the us if
it was under attack from outer space
but who knows what would happen now
though if you are lying awake at night
worried about an alien and vision we've
got you covered our best chances would
essentially be guerrilla warfare hiding
harassing and delaying aliens couldn't
just pop back home for supplies as the
travel back to wherever they came from
could take many years we need to buy
ourselves enough time to reverse
engineer their weapons if we are to
stand any chance at all in reality any
aliens who already have the technology
to travel light years through space are
well ahead of us as the legendary
Stephen Hawking fit it they will be
vastly more powerful and may not see us
as any more valuable than we see
bacteria it would be like the Roman
Empire fighting the US military today so
you can imagine they barely have a
chance to Carpe the DM before being
blown to Smithereens because of the
sheer skill of the universe alien life
has to exist somewhere
it is not a question of if there's a
question of when we will find life on
other planets in the words of Neil
deGrasse Tyson perhaps we've never been
visited by aliens because they have
looked upon Earth and decided there's no
sign of intelligent life
ouch Neil you did a sturdy
um